NITHYA SAMBASIVAN: Thank
you all for coming.
My name is Nithya.
NIBHA JAIN: Hi, I'm Nibha.
And we are both UX
researchers at Google working
on emerging markets products.
So, today, we thought we'd
come and say hi and tell you
a little bit about
emerging markets, how
they are different and unique.
And we'd like to share four
research tools with you that we
have used, tried, and tested
that work in these markets
with their unique constraints.
And then we'll leave some
time at the end for a Q&A.
If you'd like to tweet
while we're talking
or you have something
on your mind,
hashtag #EMpathy, empathy.
and, you can--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN: But also--
NIBHA JAIN: You can also talk
to us on Spaces afterwards.
Why do research?
Quick show of hands,
how many of you
have done research
for your products?
All right.
And how many of you have done
user research for your products
in emerging markets?
Awesome!
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN:
That's awesome.
NIBHA JAIN: OK
there's a few people.
So we don't have to
sell it very hard.
You are not your user.
A lot of times when we move
and develop our products,
we are moving forward
with our assumptions.
We assume that, hey,
everyone must understand
what airplane mode is.
Everyone must understand
what going offline means.
And those are just
our assumptions.
So don't assume.
Go find out what the
other person thinks.
And that's why you do research.
When you leave your studio,
your office, your workshop,
you go and meet people
in their environment.
You not only learn
about your product,
but you learn about
the way they live,
what are their constraints.
People might be living
in low light conditions.
People might work night shift.
And all of those
things you learn
when you leave your
office space and meet them
in their environment.
And lastly, speaking
as a UX researcher,
it's not just the researchers
job to do the research.
It's a team responsibility.
It doesn't matter if you're a
developer, engineer, designer,
a marketing person.
You need to be in there
getting your hands dirty.
Being there, sitting
next to the person who
is asking the questions,
asking the questions yourself,
and learning about
your product firsthand.
So yeah, just join in.
Nithya is going to
tell us a little bit
about doing research
in emerging markets.
And so I'm going to
hand it over to her.
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN: Thanks Nipa.
So emerging markets,
to begin with,
are not a homogeneous unit.
Every region, every subculture,
is different from each other.
But there are some
cross-cutting characteristics
across countries.
Over a billion
people are expected
to come online over the
next couple of years.
And a majority of
them are coming
online in the so-called
emerging markets where over 3/4
of the world's population
is concentrated.
However, there are some
unique characteristics,
technologically,
infrastructurally, socially,
or culturally, that
characterize emerging markets.
For one, while internet
is on the rise,
it can still be
slow and expensive
as a proportion of one's income.
This is Faith who
we met in Kenya.
It's a pseudonym.
Faith turns off her
mobile data every night
as she goes to sleep
because she does not want
to incur accidental charges.
Prepaid subscription
comprises the majority.
Over 95% of subscriptions
in India and South
Africa are prepaid, quite
unlike the post-pay model, which
many of us may be used to,
where a monthly balance
is automatically paid.
Prepaid involves
deliberate thinking around
what is the right plan for me.
What is the right amount?
Is it 2G, 3G, or 4G?
And this is a family
that we met in Calcutta
where they share a phone
and have a prepaid data
pack on the device.
And they go to the local
grocery store down the street
to top up their
balance every week.
And a majority of the users
that are coming online
are doing so on a mobile
device and, often, only
on a mobile phone.
This is Ardita who we met
in Jakarta in Indonesia.
And he works in a shoe factory.
And he owns a China made phone.
And the phone costs about $40.
And a lot of these
phones are sub $100.
They may have small screens.
They may have slots
for multiples SIM
cards, low internal
memory, and noncompliance.
So often, they require us
to think unconventionally
about how our apps
perform and work
in these heterogeneous devices.
So what is different about
doing research, and particularly
product development,
in emerging markets?
For one, there maybe time
and distance factors,
with time zones and
coordinating with remote teams
and travel and jet lag.
Like I mentioned,
internet is on the rise,
but it's still uneven
and still growing.
A lot of the research
methods that are designed
are designed for
wealthy populations
or for online populations.
And a lot of these
assumptions break down
when you go into
certain user context.
There are unique social,
cultural, economic norms
that characterize
emerging markets, that
affect affordability and
values around technology
and aspiration around that.
And there may be different
environmental conditions,
for example, traffic
characterizes
what people do in
their downtime,
downloading content
and listening to music
or watching videos on
the metro or in the cap.
So what this calls for is
different methodological
responses when doing product
development and research
in emerging markets.
And so our usual user
experience methods,
like A/B testing or lab
studies or online video diaries
may not work because if 15%
percent of the population
is online in a country, you're
getting a very biased response
if you're only targeting
those who are online.
And what this calls for is a mix
of analog and digital methods.
And this is what we're going
to talk to you about today,
some methods that have proven
to have success in our product
development.
NIBHA JAIN: How we do
something differently.
Those are the four tools that
we will talk to you about,
intercepts, scrolls,
immersives, and clickthroughs.
So Nithya mentioned a
lot of great challenges
that come with
being someone who's
interested in doing product
development in these markets.
So now you know
about the challenges.
You need to come up with
methods to test your product
and develop your product
despite those challenges.
You need something that will
work without connectivity
because you don't
know if you're going
to find it when you get there.
You need it to be low cost so
that you can make a lot of them
and cheaply and deploy them
and have your team use them
while you're in the field
because you're flying halfway
across the field, you need
to use your time effectively.
They are in-person.
So a lot of times, you
may rely on online surveys
or [INAUDIBLE], things like
that, where the data can
be really, really impersonal.
But because your end
user might not even
be online or know how
to use those tools,
these are in-person.
And you get more
feedback, richer feedback,
something that you can verify
was done in a good way.
And they are portable,
so they go along
with you whenever you might be.
They are resilient.
When you're in
these markets you'd
be surprised by the
number of things
your environment
might throw at you.
You might find
yourself on a boat.
You might find yourself
in a participant's home
where they have a cat, they have
a dog, they have a pet monkey.
It might happen.
It happens.
And so these methods need
to be resilient and survive
through all of those
different environments
that you might or
might not encounter.
As with every other tool,
when you are using these
through product development.
you need to know when
to use which want.
Some of them, of
course, lend themselves
to any time, anywhere, across
that product development life
cycle.
Others are more
effective when you
use them and you have something
more tangible to show people
or when you're just trying to
identify what your opportunity
space might be.
And as we go
through each method,
we will tell you which one
is a good fit for when.
So with that, Nithya is going
to tell us about intercepts.
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN: Thanks, Nipa.
So intercepts allow us to
conduct spot interviews.
And they maximize
on time and give us
a lot of learning in a
very short period of time.
So for example, this is our
team in Kampala in Uganda
where we approached a taxi
stand and spoke to taxi drivers
about how they were using
mobile devices and applications
for taxis in their day today.
So intercepts are
spot interviews
that are conducted in
naturalistic environments,
where people hang out,
relax, play, or work.
And they help us build a strong
foundational understanding
of different user groups and
the context and their practices.
So when should you
use intercepts?
Use it to gather
several data points
in a very short period of time.
It's amazing, in a day, how many
different sites and populations
that you can encounter.
For example, you could
go to the marketplace.
You could go to the
church or the template
or to the water pump and have
very different conversations
with different demographics.
Use it for broad as well
as tactical questions.
So intercepts can be
used throughout the life
cycle of the product,
in fact, early on
to build a strong foundation
of who are our users
and what their practices
and behaviors and values,
but also for very tactical,
product-specific questions
where Nipa will walk us through
some of these techniques
a little later, where
you can take in a product
prototype, or UI, and
get specific feedback
on the features.
And use it to gather
an understanding
of different demographics in
various naturalistic contexts
outside of the lab, which
is where people are.
Why should you use it?
It helps us understand how
people think and use technology
outside a lab.
Often, a lab is a good place
to get very tactical feedback.
But it is an
artificial environment
where someone comes into an
office or a conference room,
within four walls.
So intercepts help
us get out of the lab
and go around the
city or the country.
And you cut down on recruitment
and logistical costs.
You have to plan a set of
research questions and a script
and be deliberate about
which groups and sites
you want to go to.
But that's about it.
There isn't really
any cost involved
in recruiting a
particular type of users
or bringing them to the office.
So how do we go about
doing intercepts?
And each of you has a handout.
Some of you may have
the intercepts handout.
So if you don't, please
share it with your neighbor.
So the steps involved are,
as always with any research
technique, identify your goals
and come up with your questions
and then identify the
locations that you
want to visit that are
relevant to your product users.
And you can do this
in coordination
with your local team.
And once you are at a particular
site or with a user group,
establish rapport.
So you have a very short period
of time to gain their trust
and build a relationship with
your-- with the community.
Always seek permission
before you begin.
I'll talk about informed
consent in a second.
But disclose who you are.
Always seek permission
to record audio or video.
This can be hypersensitive
in some user groups.
So do seek permission.
Plan for onlookers.
You may start a conversation
with one person,
and soon, in a public
space, you may end up
with 10 other people
who are onlookers
who join the conversation.
So account for that.
And if you want to have
a private conversation,
account for that.
And take notes.
Some places and groups
that you can go to.
Remember the field
is all around you.
And so any-- a taxi ride can be
a good place for an intercept,
for example.
Gender balance.
Often, there are more men than
women in the public sphere,
so you may have to seek
out female heavy spaces.
And that may mean going
to the marketplace
or getting a haircut.
Sample on the go because this
is dynamic in the research
approach.
You don't know who
you're going to get.
So consider-- try to
balance age, gender, income
groups so you don't
end up talking
to only one type of a person.
So what's informed consent?
This is the starting point
for any research interview.
Disclose who you are,
where you come from,
what you're representing,
what is the conversation going
to be about, what are
the risks and benefits
of the conversation,
and what are you going
to do with the idea, how
you're going to collect
the information and store it.
For intercepts, often, cash
is not the right response
to thank somebody.
And that's why contextual
gifts are more helpful.
For example, when we conduct
interviews with shopkeepers,
We end up buying stuff
from their shops.
We end up with a lot
of bananas and fruit.
Consider what's
economically appropriate.
Giving a gift card
for Amazon may not
be the right thing to do
for a low income resident.
But the most important
thing, in any research,
is to stay genuine, show that
you care about their response,
listen, and that really
helps your participant
want to share more.
Mind the gap.
There is a definite gap,
often, between the researcher
and the participant.
So try to understand local
norms, local attires, phrases,
if any, and try
to bridge the gap.
This may mean
sitting on the floor,
being aware of your
surroundings and responding.
Local language is important.
So even if a community is
able to express in English,
their local language may be
what they're comfortable with,
so find interpreters.
And go light in the field.
Notebooks are-- and
going analog is often
the best way to take notes
because it's transparent.
Your participant can see
what you're capturing.
And it reduces the barrier
between you and the participant
by not having the technology
that you're typing notes into.
And it's also safe.
So in summary, that
was a lot of points.
Some steps for
conducting intercepts
are know your questions,
identify locations,
and, once you're in a location,
start by building trust
and consent, get
consent and permission,
and be aware of
the surroundings.
Respond-- if you get a
large group of people,
plan accordingly and
move accordingly.
Nipa will talk to us
about scrolls now.
NIBHA JAIN: All Right.
So Nithya mentioned, in her
last slide, going light.
And this is perfect
because scrolls are
exactly what they sound like.
They are made of paper.
And they are a lot of
paper stuck together
with tape to form one
giant roll of paper.
It's a user journey.
It's a story that you want
your user to tell you.
It's your project's journey.
But you want to hear
it from the user
and how they're interpreting
it and how they think
they will progress through it.
When should you use it?
When you are in the early
stages of development.
You know what your
problem space if.
You want to understand what's
the best way to solve for it.
You create an entire portfolio
of different concepts.
Maybe a person can listen
to songs by going online.
Maybe they can listen
to it by downloading it.
Maybe they can listen to it by
sharing it with their friends.
Maybe it's a collective app.
So there are many different ways
of solving the same problem.
And you want to go in
with your concepts.
And this is a great tool
to do that because you
can get-- it's low fidelity.
It's so cheap to make.
You can get a lot of
feedback in the same session.
It's also really
great for when you
want to capture passage of time
because it's a linear scroll.
If you want to say, imagine
that you are going on a bus
when this happened,
just put a bus there.
Or imagine, overnight, this
thing happens on your phone,
and so you just
put a moon there.
Or you went to sleep,
and the next morning you
saw something like that.
It's really easy to convey
those points of detail
through pictures.
So step 1, always
start with, what
are the goals of the study?
What are the hypotheses
that you want to test?
Map out the steps you want
to build into your journey,
and then, in the
last vignette, you
can see adding contextual cues
like if you want to put a bus,
put it there.
If you want to put an overnight
concept, put a clock or a moon
or whatever it is that
you feel comfortable with.
And then you get crafty.
You get a printer.
You print out all
the different things
that you want to
have in the story.
And you tape them all up.
You put them in
the right sequence.
And you roll it up, and
you are ready to go.
Last step, manage
the expectations
of your participants.
Tell them, hey,
this is something
that we are going
to do together.
You hold one side.
I'm going to unroll
it from this side.
You roll it back up
on the other side,
and we're going to look
at one screen at a time.
And you tell me
what is happening.
So it's a great
conversational piece.
You're breaking down
a lot of barriers.
There's no-- Nithya also
talked about minding the gap.
This is a great way to come
on the same level as them
and make them feel
useful and familiar.
You're no longer
the interviewer.
You're going through
the story together.
And you can really hear
it from their perspective.
And, of course, if after
doing this for five times,
you realize something is really,
really wrong with your story,
just untape it, stick a
few other screens in there,
and you have a new
iteration on your concept.
And you can do the next five
sessions with that version.
So it's really
cheap, really fast.
Why should you use it?
I think I talked to a
lot about these things.
When you're still in
your wireframing stage,
you don't have your app ready.
You don't have
your product ready.
This is a really good way
to get that early feedback.
It's really good for simulating
loading states because of all
the visuals that you can use.
You don't have to have deeply
complex interactions quoted up
to get responses to-- imagine
you had to wait for 10 minutes.
You don't have to get them
to wait for 10 minutes.
You can just have that
be part of your story
that you're telling
to each other.
And it really allows your
users to feel comfortable
with the medium, which is paper.
It's tactile.
It's familiar.
And it's not overwhelming, like
technology can be sometimes.
I think a bunch of you
have the scroll sheet.
So if you have it and your
neighbor doesn't, please
exchange.
And this is a good way to find
out who is sitting next to you.
Immersives.
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN:
So immersives are
activities to understand
the local experience.
Often, when we travel to
a country to do research,
it's very easy to stay within
the comfort zone of a 5 star
hotel or a nice taxi ride
or just doing the things
that we're familiar
and comfortable with.
Immersives are activities that
are planned around experiencing
the local point of view
where it's not necessarily
about an interview
or a conversation
with a participant, but it
is about using the researcher
as the instrument for research
and talking about one's
own felt experiences.
When should you use immersives?
Use it every time you
go into the field.
Step out of the office
and try to plan activities
that you can do on
your own or as a team.
Use it to complement
participant research.
You may get very
different points of view
when you experience
things for yourself.
Use it as a team to understand
various perspectives.
Each of us, in a product
team, brings together
our own values and
backgrounds and biases
and the way we see the world.
And, often, this is
a good way to go on
to participate in an
activity together and talk
about it and exchange notes on
how you felt and experienced.
Why should you do it?
You avoid parachuting
into a particular context
and gathering only
a few data points
and thinking that you
have the entire story.
Often, the story is
outside of the four walls.
So immersives help
us understand what
the larger cultural
and social context is.
And our assumptions
and hypotheses
get challenged or validated.
To build a product, we go
in with certain propositions
and assumptions.
And immersives
help us participate
in the local activities to
know if it makes sense or not.
So steps to immerse
yourself, one
is to identify activities that
are relevant for your product.
For example, if you are
building a payment system,
you may want to go
into the marketplace
and buy a few things and bargain
and see how that whole offline
process of payments works.
If you're building a
mobile application,
you may want to go into a
mobile shop, purchase a phone,
have the mobile seller
set it up for you,
top it up with mobile data,
and load a few applications
to understand really how that
particular community interfaces
with mobile phones
for the first time.
Or go to a cyber cafe to
understand how internet
is used in public places.
And the role of a social
agent in the cyber cafe
owner in educating their
customers on how to set up
an account for the first time.
Engage with your local team
for advice, or local experts
or people from a
particular country,
and really try to avoid
the touristy things.
The goal here is to understand
the everyday, mundane
experiences of the
community that you're
trying to work with.
And this may mean
taking public transport
or do what the-- in
order to understand
what people do when
they're waiting for a bus
or when they're in a crowd
versus when they have
a seat on the bus, and they
get to relax and take out
their phone.
So try to go local when you
go into a particular context.
Try to get out of
your comfort zone.
And this might mean
buying a local phone,
setting it up with a local SIM
card and a local data plan.
Some of the spaces
and activities
that are highly insightful are
marketplaces, religious sites,
where you can see how
communities come together
and what their values are,
bus rides, local sports,
getting your hair
done, and so on.
So step 2 is to allow
time to acclimatize.
For any international
research trip
there is jet lag in travel.
So account for that.
Different people
respond differently
to stress in the field.
And field work is really
tiring and challenging,
as exhilarating as it can be.
So account for that.
Understand how your team members
respond to stress and plan
activities around that.
Safety first.
And balance work with fun.
It's important to take
breaks in the field
and step away for some time
in order to regain your lens.
So in your handouts,
you have all the steps.
And back to Nipa.
NIBHA JAIN: All right.
So this is our fourth and final
research tool, clickthroughs.
And again, I'm in charge of
all the literal methods here.
Clickthroughs are exactly
what they sound like.
It's a bunch of images
put in a serial order.
Have you guys used
clickthroughs before?
Raise your hand if
you've used one.
Excellent.
OK.
So this is basically
a low fidelity version
of what we are used to here.
It's a collection of images
put in a serial order.
And you put them on your
phone, and you're ready to go.
It gives you an
illusion of progress
because when you
tap on one image,
it goes to the next
image naturally.
So you can imagine that
you're clicking on a button,
and that's taking you
to the next screen.
But it's just the
program progressing
through static images.
When should you use it?
Again, while you're waiting
for the actual product
to be coded and
programmed, you can
go in with early
wireframes or low fidelity
mocks or high fidelity mocks.
So this is something
that you would
use towards the [INAUDIBLE]
end of your product development
cycle when you're ready
to go, but you're still
waiting for those final
interactions to come in.
More importantly, the
version that we're
going to share with
you today is about not
relying on the internet.
So this works
completely offline.
You can use it wherever and
on whichever devices you like.
So a lot of times,
you will encounter
forms that are on
all GMS calls or have
outdated versions
of whatever it is
that you were trying to test.
You'll just find
ridiculous things
when you go out in the field.
And this will overcome
any of those things
because phones-- all phones
have photo galleries,
and so you can work with that.
This is something
that you will use
to make it more real
than it actually is.
So you can do a lot of amazing
smoke and mirror techniques
because you're basically
creating an illusion of control
and progression without having
to code any of those buttons
in.
Again, start with the tasks
that you want to test.
Make up the rough
screens that you
want to depict in that task.
In what order
should they appear?
And if you're working
on slides, you're
working on Illustrator,
Sketch, whatever
is the program of your choice
where you're developing
your screens, you
take screenshots
that would be the exact
same size of the phone
or it matches the
phone size so that it
looks like a live
screen on the phone.
Once you've got all your
screenshots in place,
rename those in
the right order so
that they appear
in the right order
when you have them
on your phone.
So you can go
Homepage, screen 1.
When I click on the
tab, that's screen 2.
When it shows up a search
button, that's screen 3.
Whatever is the progression,
rename it accordingly.
And then get your
images onto your phone.
Get into the gallery.
Find that folder.
Click on the first image.
Put it in full screen mode, and
your prototype is ready to go.
Of course, for a lot of
these participants-- and you
can also, of course,
use something
like a peer-to-peer sharing
app, like SHAREit or Xender
and put it on your
participant's phone.
So they get a really good
first-hand experience of,
imagine this app
was on your phone.
And that's a very
different response
that you would get from,
hey, on my Nexus 6,
this looks like this.
What do you think?
And they've never seen
a screen that size.
So this makes it
really versatile.
And once you are with them, you
can set the expectations of,
hey, when you click,
it'll go to the next one.
So before you click
on it, tell me
what you think is
happening here.
And then what do you
expect will happen
when you click on this button?
And then you progress
through the next one.
So you manage their
expectations a little bit,
and then you basically
hand it over.
And it's also really easy to
do this for feedback collection
because you already know what
were the screens that you were
testing, so you can
summarize all your findings
at the end of that day.
You say, on screen 1, we
found these things were great.
These are the things
that we need fix.
And on screen 2, people
were really confused about
what was happening.
We really need to go back and
look at that problem again.
So this is our summary of an
offline clickthrough prototype
using a phone gallery.
So if you have
comments, thoughts,
do tag them with
hashtag #EMpathy.
All right.
Thank you.
NITHYA SAMBASIVAN:
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]